[Music]
brought to you by watchdogs hacking is
your weapon available now
Heil brothers and sisters welcome back
to top 5 Skyrim months of the week or as
we call in the office step forward
Smart's hail hail - smarts I'm cam and
we thought it's about time we told you
that we actually don't refer to this
show in the office as top 5 scalable -
because that's too long no it takes too
long
welcome to smart we simply call it
smarts mods are you ready for a small
number one I'm ready for smart number
one it's gets modding welcome sent to
smart number one which this week is
alternate start live another life
I'll explain while we're in the menu
screen that's cuz I love the menu screen
and also also I've actually used this
mod before at my own save at home
nothing to do with work this is this is
cam Fry's Rob approve and this is how it
starts okay you must mean to push
there's no foreplay it's just no
foreplay straight to character chose who
are you who straight into here yes name
prisoner so basically the way this works
save is you start off by making
character as per usual okay and then you
get a whole lot of other choices let's
start with the characters who are we
gonna make well I was thinking Kevin van
org you have you've earned your fifty
pence today I tell you another day
another million dollars haha
Kevin vans bass oh shut up Kevin van or
keys give a knock hello a statue of Mara
vigilante that's that's pretty good no
firm answer living in Orca stronghold we
are an orc attacked and left for dead
what quite like that so Fallout New
Vegas buddy but you know chem van orc
would never be attacked and defeated as
a vampire in a secluded lair I quite
like an outlaw in the wine yeah out more
in the wiles go for that
okay we're with another buddy apparently
hey Chum depending on what you choose
you will have different equipment that
you start with right now we actually
started off with loads of stuff yes we
start with a readme for the mod so all
the information of the mod is in here
okay 10 pushes a feeling no that's not
bad but yes I just drunk one nine pushes
on yeah yeah you got you've all nine of
them you got in despair die kevin van
orc demands it
hey his first kill da look at Wiess camp
so this is where we start its
the hills let's have a look at the map
see where we are exactly yeah well not
for us giving solo tutorial stuff so you
know we're not actually far from
Markarth the introduction to Dragon
still needs to happen yes exactly
Sam look how fast just down when it goes
down you know i knows cuz we're not
careful about our stamina low find the
Dragons victim inside helmets this is a
whole new Helgen quest what's happening
here what happened here at algún aha a
burned corpse activate the body turns to
ash did you touch it with somehow I left
the journal survived the attack yes
somehow alright so look at this this
indestructible journal dragon proof okay
investigate a cave mage in the journal
or warn the residence of Riverwood about
the dragon attack ah I like Riverwood
sev should we get rid of it yeah let's
do it
so maybe my mother isn't crazy
afterwards nope no she no she is she cry
cry needs to know about this alright and
that's it and now we're into the regular
quest and talk to the Earl of white runs
okay so it just bypasses that initial
bit really gives you an it gives you I
am much quicker route into heading over
to white running and starting their
quest proper and there you go so we have
a complete new start into Skyrim
remember depending on which one of those
options you chose when we spoke to the
statue you get a completely different
starting location and bit of backstory
and also equip it so but I like it
because you know it kind of gets you
into the game just that little bit
quicker than the original start which is
sort of like you've got all the
backstory and everything and so I guess
if you've already played Skyrim which
before which you're gonna have I mean I
don't I don't really see anyone using
this who hasn't played the game before
really they're vanilla beginning is
wonderful but it's when you've seen it
once you want to try something new it
certainly gives you that okay everyone
time for some odd number two which this
week is achieve that mmm what's this one
all that said okay so this mod adds
in-game achievements and that might not
sound like it does very much at all but
it's it's to do with you know the things
that the game asks you to do so learn
how to Smith learn how to do this and
money you know kill people but instead
of it just being an arbitrary task that
sort of helps you earn your perks now it
gives you actual in-game rewards so
awesome if you've got so much money
it'll go
oh you're real good at saving but have a
bonus in this and the way you can find
out all of these different ones is by
going to its new MCA many so in here
you've got your general character on
categorized at hall of glory rewards and
tasks so go you can see for Kevin
because he's a millionaire a very rich
man he's he's already achieved the task
of millionaire great what does it give
us well even give it a click you can
have a look ok give it a click plus 15
carrying capacity a reward for bounty
but actually there's a surprise
so we've already reached 40,000 oh
another 10% chance for a critical hit
yes we'll have that now some of them are
red and it means I think this ones you
can no longer achieve so you know these
are level based it's like they have done
this thing within this time in it and we
we haven't so maybe this is a good more
to add from the beginning yeah along
with an alternate start as you really
get a deer yeah you actually get perks
for putting in all that hard work
wonderful this is a really great model I
like it okay time for the third smart of
today and said this one is called
one-handed crossbows which I think's
pretty much describes what it does in a
10 or less more than no let's whip them
out double cross post your wheel oh wow
so these are custom-made crossbows as
you can probably tell because you know
by default they're only really good oh I
got in the way once uh-oh
but as you probably notice they they're
a little bit weaker as I suppose you'd
expect them from something being you
know one-handed yeah but the thing is
also they are powered by magic if you if
you notice like you know you're not
losing bolts now and you get the cool
magic effects as well and you use them
you certainly do so the way it kind of
works is each one of the of these
one-handed crossbows has a charge okay
so make it a little bit more law
friendly the more creator has added what
he describes his bolts which he can find
when you go and collect these particular
crossbows
yeah but they effectively act like a
soldier does that make sense we've got
the dragon bone one-handed crossbow look
at that yeah man that's pretty brittle
it's pretty nice
I see a Kaveri one yeah I like that they
Reno's because they can't if they did a
real good blades a Kaveri thing and it
kind of gets ignored you know in in all
other parts apart from the the sword
yeah so it's nice that it finally gets a
little bit of an odd man it looks pretty
mean I like this so here we have a war
van one set which again looks quite
different from the the Dwarven crossbows
we're used to you I like it because it's
it always looks like it's got a magazine
does he does yeah attached to it and
then and then the last one is the
nocturnal crossbow yeah this is really
cool so what's going on here
it's a kind of like a bit of a Daedric
thing going on Big Pharma meets a
Daedric or something yeah cool I like a
lot I see insignia on their kind of
eagle thing yeah I know about it it's
not a surprise at all I don't want to
keep saying I brought you man these are
quite weak yeah you can kind of like
sink him up there yeah this didn't get
this gonna resin going yeah it's not bad
once you get that final mid end double
fire yeah pretty good or bad this guy
I'm trying to kill the old guy very good
hit good all right and she got someone
far away you can kill the near guys with
it with your axe and then hit the range
guys or your rapid fire yeah crossbow
that's a cheat that's pretty good you
know like that's something that holds
you up all the time you've got no ranged
weapon yeah Skyrim apart from magic yeah
there is one-handed so you know well so
now you do yeah I think that's too high
now yes I got him haha hit one hit off
his horse how do I kill no not not noble
noble speak to me speak to me but
breathe breathe oh my gosh oh I'm so
sorry pal Edda stripped him run nothing
wait wait wait
beavis horse
it's time for small number for sab and
we are in the bards college because this
mod is cold become a bar I've always
wanted to become a bard can hear bard
singing down the songs down the halls
usually it's just us beautiful now see
steel steel drum now we got our own drum
and already well equipped so if we ask
what he's got for sale here we show so a
war horn a lute a Nord horn oh wow let's
just buy it all and it music easy yeah
man I don't know why everyone's
complaining it's real hard to become a
virtuoso because this is we are learning
system like matrix level learning right
so oh did you know you know songs are
the black marsh no but I do now
I know coffee fighting haha fast as
lightning did it did it did it did it do
Oh achievement unlocked sad whoa
bookworm yeah I was busy barding oh
we've showcased a different mod look at
how it all ties together play war horn
go
we are real good Wow
I think that might be Kevin Bernard
mating I was just thinking that I'm
ready for love it's the only way I found
any successful with yeah yeah
yeah I gotta try that this evening
instead of her like a walrus lute songs
let's try leaps on them before
while we're so good I can't nonchalant
he is because such nimble fingers I
still think your war was bad oh yes try
the imperial world
I'm done yeah it's over no history
lovemaking Jewish shut up that is the
ultimate commit conversation yeah ruiner
it's like that's so rude
like sir are you saying something I just
I just got to do a thing I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you over the sound of God
he's talented love butter that done me
Lou
perhaps you'd like a song oh she's
dancing she's dancing notice kevin has
the ability to sing two voices at the
same time and that is also because
become a bard allows your follower to
jewett with you
[Music]
she's done she's out yeah Bucky was
really enjoying this he was yeah I don't
know as somehow he made Scarborough Fair
sexy while he's giving so much
this is the best thing ever this is
fantastic
dance for me the rhythm it's infectious
I was going to but I'd do that thing
from Alabama but oh yeah oh this is hot
this part the audience is really kicking
off left hand side is karakurt dejected
moustache-man licks in the background
there's like I was dancing before it was
due I was there first I was the original
fan I don't like this
I love how those ones are like I were
done oh wait we can't leave no nothing
for it but to come here Lance
well now you're all suitably seduced oh
they didn't like that at all
Oh Oh God she liked it oh I think he
found your partner burr the mating call
of the van Nord
it carries across and hey - all right
save time for the final mod of this week
what number five and that's blaze of
even ties yes so tell me a little bit
about this monster well this mods pretty
cool cam I know that we don't use horses
very often in this in this particular
play through Skype sure we don't but if
we were to use one he'd need to be
pretty cool it needs to be dangerous and
explosive basically pretty much so we
have a perfect mount wonderful for our
Skyrim
he is blaze and he is summonable that
straight your skipper go all right good
spell casting there Kevin Wow there he
is you even hop straight on amazing look
at this guy hold from the fiery depths
of hell that cannot be comfortable to
sit on oh not for Kevin with his
asbestos but the blaze has basically
been custom-made which is what makes him
so awesome so yeah it's got fire in his
Mane he's got fire in his eyes got fire
on his feet he's got fire kind of coming
out of his arse a little bit there and
that's brutal
he's even little fiery hoof print
but if you were to get off him and let
him defend himself here yeah you'll
notice that something happens to these
wolves and that Sabre cat they're all on
fire oh wow
so you actually sets fire to the things
that he kills oh I love them I love them
a bit much but there's more there's more
to blaze apart from the fact that he's
well strong well but when when you need
more than just a bit of you know fiery
kicking yes there's one extra thing the
place is prepared to do it I guess throw
himself down a death's door for you so
this is blaze deployment let's give this
a go do it all right got him oh here we
go oh it's going off whoa Jesus people
hours over the top he will detonate for
you ah no no you was Wow yeah that was
awesome though the leeches the fiery
remains here poor blaze I mean you can
you can bring him back but he can only
blow up once a day oh why was fair
enough I mean it's quite a lot to ask
him to do that more than once a day so
sure yeah hurts it hurts him again but
let's bring him back because he was
wonderful I love this guy I really love
every part of this mod and what's more
is it's loads of effects at AAG level so
you can have him cast light when he
walks or not you can have that toggle so
that when you're in sneak he won't cast
light you know it too basically so you
can have him be as helpful or as much of
a hindrance as you bought amazing and he
will just follow me if I run around like
yes again another thing that you can
toggle you can have him stay where you
are
he's ass yeah blaze is the ultimate the
ultimate travel companion and he's on
fire and he's on fire out of his ass
alright so I think there's just one
thing left to do and that's introduced
blaze you had just noticed the amazing
detail and its saddle there oh yeah so
no yeah you had that it's of yourself oh
it is himself yeah it's the sigil of him
little desired running towards someone
to blow up yeah well let's make him blow
up these chickens all 100 of Myranda so
uh which one's been really bad
this one a guy how about him oh dear
it's a bad day to be you oh look at that
I love we can see where I came from wow
I might be one of the finest launches ah
that is I love her we got a view from
rushing from where we started so far we
have blasted across skyrim plays
incredible you're a champion the
champion bull horses the Lord of all my
friend free my fred fern age all right
sir Blair with some fantastic mods but
let's get to our questions and comments
absolutely sure freshmen from today well
the first one is from Ben Parker hey Ben
asks if a mod is available on both the
Nexus and steam which way would you
choose to install it and why personally
I think I would choose the Nexus so a
tie just because when you do stuff
through the Steam Workshop
it comes into that data files bit in the
normal launcher and sometimes you can
get some crossover where you know you
activate it there and then you're going
to the Nexus mod manager and they won't
quite communicate and sometimes stuff
they will actually fail to look properly
yeah so it's just easier if everything's
on one platform so I would say Nexus
yeah I would say as well also because
that you seem to usually get a slight
more fleshed out mod yet in Exeter often
a lot of things get skipped in there in
the workshop version it seems to be like
a lightweight but you know what the
workshops great because it's a great
introduction to morning you've all done
before so don't get me wrong
we love the workshop - yeah alright next
question is from Andrew Pollitz and this
was tweeted at you sir because I already
said we go I understand how the chickens
work now which gives us on this
fantastic wonderful I've read this paper
through I know frankly it is exactly a
few readings yeah but I agree I now
understands but as a man of science I
appreciate this greatly this flowchart
the chicken flowchart especially really
close things are my favourite bits of
formula if it's chicken then chicken
yeah you do while chicken chicken
chicken
Jake Oris of course case chicken yeah
lots of chickens this formula clears
things up yeah a fascinating read I've
to encourage anyone it is there's pretty
advanced stuff so oh yeah but you know
dude give me your best shot
yeah wonderful thanks so much for
sending that along
that's awesome and I next one is from
Josh Abel who says hey do you have an
NPC mod of Kevin if not you so should do
that but we never we've never made a mod
yeah but I think if we were to make a
mod that would be the first mod we make
that would be good let's let's look into
that that's a great idea all right all
right well well maybe we'll do some
collaborations you know get some voice
actors in yeah yeah voice actors you say
some voice acted I have a variety of
emotion alright next alright we won't
voice it okay and the last one is from
Keira winstram one strum is it really
words true Wednesday when strim okay
nice enough listen I've got a degree in
Bologna saw this and all I could think
was
goodbye alpacas we hardly knew this
videos amazing like I can't watch this
without getting really nervous
I really really does make me nervous
I just keep it to my tune see them like
gathering don't step someone they chase
look I know chase hard but they do
change chase apparently the alpacas are
guarding the chickens too Dora and I
feel like maybe that guy there should
really be guarding everything because
this is danger I'm so scared it's danger
quick quick close it close it much much
and done all right
good questions good question now
obviously and we have a whole load of
more mods to vote on for next week yes
we've had so many great suggestions
lately we get tons of them out on
amazing like at least very ten a day
this race sorry about that for nestor
duplicates but man yeah coming it makes
our job really easy I love it so the
ones we have for the vote this week or
should I say next week yes and next
week's show are the armor of more like
ball this looks pretty mean I like that
especially because you can get the mace
of Molag Bal's so why not be on the
whole armor and then next you have the
chicken Returns
Center this way a follower who
apparently does some weird random and
rather wonderful things I can't wait to
see that lighting I've got feeling that
was gonna win but maybe I'll actually be
divine Aegis HD paladin style ebony
armoire rehaul yeah it's real all even a
word I don't even know overhaul rehaul
whatever you can you can rehaul
yourselves over
the vote link you're so fired huh you
can do that at 10 you are our by the
part of fire you
I don't you he's actually more senior
than me goddamnit
well the link ow all right that the link
is Tonya Elcom /r Eddie SEBI blog I
might fly you
I might just don't like for that go
there click on the vote what you want
the mod you want a vote and if everyone
else agrees you or most people do it
will showcase it we have so easy easy
and if you want to just suggest once for
us to use on the show then you can get
in touch with us on Twitter
yep at count four as Rob already said we
go let us know send us links we get
loads sent to us which is great so thank
you so much for everyone who does that
absolutely no Seb next week very
exciting yeah we're not gonna be here
new but we are gonna do the show
but not from here no from our office in
San Francisco running San Francisco
Emmet said we're going to America
yeah well they're letting us in I know
well we'll see we'll see people see got
my visa but you know they could still
say no yeah and I will bring you use top
five square modes of the week live or
not live but from from the office
hopefully we're there for some special
guests very special guests yeah maybe
maybe Kevin banner would himself Oh
that'd be brilliantly that's maybe he's
a busy man but we'll see what we can do
right I can't I gotta say mm-hmm I love
your t-shirt I love you t-shirt to say
these are nice always go we're wearing
this and we are oh one of us can have to
change oh okay that's what you're in a
onesie Wow
these t-shirts these t-shirts are from
our sisters like exco ex car please
check them out and you could also win
ones yeah yeah there you go go check out
ex car yeah well that's it for another
week until we are over in America expect
me to be jet-lagged absolutely I arrived
a few days after this man so I'll be
really jet-lagged we record the show but
I'll try and Lucas spritely a spot get
it done for you thank you for you guys
alright see you next week
[Music]
brought to you by watchdogs hacking is
your weapon available now